so for the beginning writer what's the
most lacking in it for beginning writer
instruction yes well scene is one and
one of the many things in other words
craft I mean if you're beginning writer
you gotta learn the craft and only you
gotta learn you got to practice it so
you will not I mean unless you're a
genius who does this instinctively which
is a possibility you will not accomplish
this in your first script I mean if you
read the 101 habits most screenwriters
who sold their script was usually was
their tenth or fourteenth script and
usually I've been working on it for many
many years so it takes practice you know
just like any other craft takes practice
and so learn the craft and practice the
craft the other thing too you should you
should know is that there's a lot of
information out there about storytelling
about screenwriting a lot of how-to
books and you got to understand you know
I always recommend read them all you
know I mean I'm a lifelong learner I
read everything I always try to learn
you know always always always and when
you see the same thing being told and
you you got it that's what I called the
basics once you learn the basics then
you got to go beyond that right and
that's what I try to do in my writing
for emotional impact book I go beyond
the basics you know the book is
structured with all the main elements of
screenwriting you know storytelling
concept theme character story scenes
description dialogue and the first part
is the basics all the stuff that you
should know by now and now I'm going to
teach you the craft which is what really
you should worry about which is you know
what is the effect of your writing on a
reader on an audience you know and your
audience will be a reader a reader will
be the first year first line of defense
somebody's gonna read your script and if
they're not engaged by your writing
they're not turning the pages then you
failed you're done so you got to learn
how to do it you got to learn how to
hold somebody's attention and you got to
learn how it's done would you see that
the obstacle not being clear sometimes
is the number one thing that's that's
part of it yeah yeah in terms of actual
symptoms yeah I mean there's there's
writers who do not understand conflict
they don't know
what conflict is the right scenes that
are mostly two people talking and just
revealing exposition so it's kind of
like they just want the audience to know
certain things about their character or
their past or about the story but this
is the writers intention in the scene
not the characters intention so you get
these scenes are just basically talking
heads just exposition that's the most
boring thing there is you know we're not
we're not crap no matter how interesting
the information is so conflict lack of
goal we don't know what a character
wounds or we don't care about the
character or the scenes are just you
know what they're talking about what the
story is about is kind of cliche we've
seen that story 100 times you know the
concept is you know what I call soft
concepts there there's nothing in the
concept to make me want to see the story
you know when you think about how you
choose to watch a movie you know usually
you see the poster or you see a tagline
or you see a trailer you can you can
tell you can like analyze how you feel
about it when you see it you know you go
you know usually for me it's the concept
when and when I know what a concept is
about when I read about a script that's
sold and they say you know story is
about this and this and this you know so
you have the logline right there I know
whether the movies gonna be successful
not just from that because it's either
the laga has a hook to it and you go oh
my god that's interesting or you know
and that feeling that huh is what that's
why producers or agent upon request your
scripts because they're just you know
this the concept is just too flat or
cliche but if something is really
there's a hook to it they're gonna at
least request the script and they're
gonna read it now the script might be
flawed and it's gonna get a pass anyway
but at least think it's going to be
requested so if you really have a great
concept which is what I recommend go for
that make sure your concept has a hook
you